governor newsome
his uh ex-wife jennifer newsom
jennifer siebold newsom i think that is
her name yes she called me and she set
up a meeting with me to meet her someone
in brentwood and i actually went and i
got very like creeped out and i saw her
sitting where a sister meet her and i
looked at her and i i turned around and
went back into my car and drove away she
wanted to meet me she reached out to me
before we completely lose the uh the
political part yeah the new the newsome
party so
yeah no it all sort of fits but i know
you've got something you wanted to talk
about about newsom
specifically yes dave thank you for
reminding me
oh i feel like hal 2000
yes dave
no dave sorry dave no dave sorry dave
that's strange so yes governor newsom
his uh ex-wife jennifer newsom
jennifer siebold news him i think that
is her name yes she called me and she
set up a meeting with me to meet her
someone in brentwood and i actually went
and i got very like creeped out and i
saw her sitting where her sister meet
her and i looked at her and i i turned
around and went back into my car and
drove away she wanted to meet me she was
when is this when is this just this is
about uh six months before the new york
times article in weinstein that i set up
broke
okay and she called me on behalf of a
therapist board member
the
lawyer for
long time lawyer of hillary and bill and
clinton and weinstein
won david boyce so this woman i don't
know some blonde lady named with the
last name of newsome cold calls me and
it's like
david boyce wants to know what it would
take
to make you happy
six months before the weinstein story
what do it take to make you happy which
you took as for those that might be
playing along a little bit slowly
i i don't know but i don't know if it
would be fiscal remuneration i don't
know i like absolutely nothing would
make me happy you falling off the planet
david boyce and your whole company if
you all fall off the planet i would be
happy since you cannot do that
i will remain unhappy with you and you
shall deal with my displeasure
but they're scary these are operators
they're tied into sdk knickerbocker
they're tied into hillary they're tied
into nancy pelosi this is all backdoor
[ __ ] for their gain and we're tired
of it we're suffering people are dying
not just because stupid ass cold but
because their [ __ ] system is [ __ ]
killing us i've had it and i think a lot
of us had so now it's time to go from
feeling i feel this is all [ __ ] to
fact it is all [ __ ] and vote larry
elder because why why the [ __ ] not what
have you got to lose how's it going
people how's your system right society
working for you try something different
might as well
there's my pitch
like a pro like a pro the best campaign
like you know i just like for me like i
used to volunteer years ago at a place
called covenant house and i never did it
with cameras and i would go and i would
speak to homeless runaway uh trans kids
which you know um because i was taken in
by them when i was a homeless 13 year
old that's who raised me they were like
my mothers right so i always felt like i
would repay the favor and i knew that
state-run therapy could not help them in
the way that i could because i don't use
language the same way most people do and
i'm not scared so when a kid when the
the therapist would say this goes
together with this how did that make you
feel
and they're like
they're like [ __ ] the hard shell comes
up that doesn't make me feel anything
and and i because i'm not bound by state
laws or regular normal ways conversing
which is why i'm effective i believe
is is is simply because i said
really
that would hurt me so badly
i would feel so betrayed and abandoned
if the person i came here with abandoned
me on the first day left me to rot on
the streets i that would like
shake my faith humans and everything
else and i feel like that is what the
state of california needs to say to
gavin newsom on election day you have
betrayed us you have hurt us you and
your whole type because you are one in a
long line of lizards and we don't want
you anymore i like lizards i like real
lizards but i don't like the fake
lizards
so clean house you can do it go to the
polls do it for me because i'm not gonna
he got this
just to be totally clear here gavin
newsom's
wife
or ex wanted to sit or wanted to sit
down with you which then turned out to
be on the phone where she said
what
can harvey weinstein's lawyer do
to make this story go away gavin what's
the connection to gavin newsom's wife
why why was it that she was the one that
was calling you
mystified me too because they tried
every way they could they tried every
single way they could to get to me i
mean my literary agency duprey miller
who i hired to represent me to shepherd
and protect my book from weinstein
jan miller
it's a big literary firm and they
were secretly exposed they were exposed
for secretly working with weinstein the
entire time they're supposed to be
protecting my book
uh they were exposed to the new york
times for that and when i met her this
jan miller woman she was bragging about
like giving a fifteen thousand dollar
plate dinner for david boyce and bill
and hillary that night in dallas so you
know do the math it's all connected it
is all connected one at a time i am
coming
yeah i mean that seems like a fairly big
scandal with an election coming in four
days basically
i guess in my world it's like tuesday at
2 p.m it's just like
another order like literally do you know
the governor's wife calling me to you
know basically shut me up with money
about the biggest sex scandal of all
time
it's a serial rapist and i i load the
media they're always like disgraced
producer i'm like if he was an indigent
black rapist would you say disgraced
disgraced homeless rapist no he is a
convicted
serial rapist let's just say it we can
all be adults it wasn't pleasant it
wasn't fun they really built a beast in
me and all i ever wanted to do my whole
life dave was lay under a tree at night
in the grass and look for owls
i know i know i know that's true with
you you love the owls and we've got this
very bizarre owl connection we both have
owls hanging outside our houses not in
part two but so i said the things if
there are people out there that can go
in on this and and work it out and
expose more yes they're all part of it
and this whole like oprah saying like or
meryl streep or uh gavin needs him oh we
were in our ivory tower we just didn't
know anything about it we're too fancy
for that that's just those you know the
little actresses they wore short skirts
they deserved it no
this was a machine this is a machine it
has many many tentacles one tentacles
the human trafficking arm of it right he
had a daily appointment for rape 1pm
around 1 pm every day daily appointment
for many years anywhere there's a film
festival and it takes
his protection i introduced hillary at
aussie fest about three something years
ago
in central park so it's like it was like
a rock concert for speakers so they got
me up there and at this point i just
really found out how deep involved in
this whole thing like that camp was
right um and that it hadn't really been
publicly outed yet by me or anybody
and so they said okay so you're gonna
introduce hillary and i'm like great
i got this
so the last thing i said to this like it
was like a rock concert right i'm up
there
and i said
and the last thing i will say to you all
today
harvey weinstein was protected by the
democratic party welcome to the stage
hillary clinton
and this collective
nordstrom liberal gasp
like and suddenly i was literally like
yanked off stage they wouldn't let me go
backstage see my purse i'm walking out
of central park i see her like town car
go by see the hair like you know and
profile and i just see your face like in
profile go
and i was like nailed it
wow but i can i serve i serve why
because i was born to
is there video of that i mean that
it's got to be somewhere
maybe let's say i looked for it on their
site but of course now you know they
take down everything
but it like somebody out there has that
video i was certainly i certainly did it
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell